Mais non, Alice, écoutez,
j'ai un client qui arrive ici d'une minute à l'autre.
C'est moi le client.
Désolée, Léon, c'est le seul moyen
que j'ai trouvé pour avoir un peu de votre temps.
Pardon ?
J'ai une idée pour vendre mieux
nos appareils de prise de vue.
Une secrétaire avec des idées !
On n'arrête pas le progrès.
J'ai hâte d'entendre ça.
Qu'est-ce que je suis en train de regarder, Alice ?
Une histoire.
- Une histoire !
Vous connaissez la légende qui raconte
que les garçons naissent dans les choux.
On est où là ?
Dans un jardin d'enfants ?
Les gens aiment les histoires, Léon.
Je pense que nous devrions utiliser
nos appareils pour fabriquer des histoires avec,
que les gens prendraient plaisir à regarder.
Comme ils aiment se plonger dans un bon livre.
Si on les fait rêver avec notre appareil,
c'est sûr, ils voudront l'acheter.
Des histoires sur film ?
Mais oui.
On prendrait des comédiens de théâtre
et on capturerait leurs prestations
avec notre appareil.
Oui.
Et pour "La fée aux choux", j'ai pensé à tout.
Je vais fabriquer les costumes,
les décors, les accessoires.
Puis ensuite,
on construirait une salle avec des sièges
et les spectateurs viendraient, après le souper,
voir les petites histoires primesautières
concoctées par Mademoiselle Alice.
Et on pourrait même leur faire payer l'entrée !
Voilà !
Mais c'est formidable !
C'est formidable !
J'aurais tout entendu aujourd'hui.
Je vous demande pardon,
j'ai toujours eu une imagination débordante.
Cela dit, elle ne trouve écho
que chez ceux qui ont de l'ambition.
Il y aurait peut-être de meilleures ventes
si vous faisiez votre travail, Alice.
Lave-toi les dents, Félix.
Je vous en prie, Léon.
Laissez-moi essayer.
Écoutez, Alice,
nos clients achètent nos appareils
pour documenter les scènes du quotidien,
la nature, le travail, un train qui rentre en gare.
On n'a pas pour vocation de vendre des histoires,
mais vendre du matériel professionnel.
Vous ne vous rendez pas compte
du potentiel de notre appareil.
C'est mon appareil
et je compte le vendre comme je l'entends.
Léon,
je pense que Gaumont
a le pouvoir de faire rêver les gens,
ses clients,
même le monde entier.
Comme Gutenberg avant vous, comme Jules Verne,
ou comme Mozart.
Léon, de qui se souvient-on aujourd'hui ?
De Mozart
ou de celui qui lui a vendu son piano ?
Je ferai cela
en dehors de mes horaires de travail,
vous ne le remarquerez même pas.
C'est promis.
N'insistez pas.
Cadeau.
Si tu veux mon avis,
ses choux, elle les fume.
Alors, comment ça s'est passé ?
C'est simple,
j'aurais pu leur parler du droit de vote
ou de la recette du canard à l'orange,
ça aurait été pareil.
Ils ne m'écoutaient pas.
Mais ce n'est pas une lubie, Ernestine.
Je te comprends, Alice.
Nous les femmes, on a besoin de se réaliser.
Oui.
Et moi, ma marotte, c'est le crochet.
Mais si tu veux, je vais te passer une pelote,
une paire d'aiguilles,
parce que j'en ai toujours une en plus.
Parce que c'est quand même important
de savoir faire quelque chose de ses dix doigts.
Artistiquement, il se passe quelque chose.
Et puis, ça fait plaisir, le crochet.
Ça fait plaisir à soi, aux autres.
Je rends mon mari heureux.
Et un mari heureux, ça n'a pas de prix.
À condition que votre courrier n'en souffre pas.
Léon Gaumont.